this video is brought to you by policy
genius who you have family members who
depend on your income you need life
insurance and that's where policy genius
comes in more on them in a bit
an ancient evil a scourge a curse
embroiled in a bitter feud against
humanity since the dawn of time from the
cradle of the first sapiens it walked
with us among us inside us whenever our
first villages towns and cities sprung
whenever our civilization expanded the
enemy was there silent and undetected
ready for the cull it could happen at
any time it started with a cough that
wouldn't go away then the first droplets
of blood and sputum stained the palm of
your hand and then your pale body
started to waste away as if it was being
consumed from the inside our forefathers
used to call it the wasting disease
thysis consumption white plague today we
know it as tuberculosis the deadliest
disease to ever crawl the earth
[Music]
the main responsible pathogen of
tuberculosis or tb is the mycobacterium
tuberculosis this microorganism has
accompanied humans throughout every
stage of our history during which time
it may have killed more people than any
other living being before we get into
the history of this disease let's
quickly profile it the bacterium
tuberculosis usually attacks the lungs
of the host but it can affect also the
spine brain and other organs the
infection does not always result in
manifest illness therefore there are two
tb-related conditions latent tb
infection and tb disease people with
latent infection do not have any
symptoms they appear generally healthy
and are not contagious they can however
test positive for the disease and in
later stages can develop a full-on
infection if their immune system is
weakened it may take up to 40 years
before the mycobacterium reactivates and
starts attacking its host from the
inside on the other hand patients who
live in an environment in which tb is
highly prevalent or who have a weak
immune system may develop active tb
disease and fall ill from the start in
most cases they will experience a bad
cough lasting three weeks or longer they
will develop acute chest pain and
eventually they may cough up blood other
visible signs include fatigue weight
loss fever night sweats and a sickly
pala these patients will spread them
tuberculosis in the air as they cough or
even speak thus infecting those near
them family members friends schoolmates
and co-workers are all particularly at
risk when a healthy host breathes in the
tb bacteria these will settle inside the
lungs in most cases once in the lungs
the bacterial will lead to necrosis of
the healthy tissue causing the formation
of cavities and hard nodules the
tubercules that lend their name to the
disease as they attack the pulmonary
tissue the bacteria can erode blood
vessels which causes the person to cough
up bright red blood and if the infection
enters the bloodstream the mycobacteria
can spread throughout the body causing
miliary tuberculosis tuberculosis
meningitis or other variants of the
disease such as potts disease which
causes spinal deformity in all cases the
ruthless basili of the mycobacterium
genus will set to work causing a process
called caseiation from the latin word
for cheese what happens is the invaders
will destroy healthy tissue leaving in
their place a thick cheesy substance if
the progressive erosion reaches a major
artery the patients may die of internal
hemorrhage otherwise they may experience
a longer more painful death as their
organs fail one after the other from the
outside patients will appear as if
consumed from the inside slowly wasting
away to an unseen vampire inside their
own body
the genus mycobacterium may have
originated more than 150 million years
ago later evolving into an ancestor of m
tuberculosis this was present in east
africa as early as three million years
ago when it may have infected early
hominids in fact the skull of a
000 year old homo erectus was found to
present lesions compatible with
tuberculosis meningitis much later about
15 to 35 000 years ago another strain
appeared which gave origins the modern m
tuberculosis and its related variants
including m bovis responsible for bovine
tb then from east africa early human
hosts migrated to neighboring lands and
then throughout the world carrying the
scourge buried deep inside their lungs
the next forensic evidence of death by
tb was found on the skeletons of a young
woman and a child they were found in the
submerged village of atletian israel
destroyed by a tsunami some 9 000 years
ago in 2008 a team from university
college london confirmed that the
unhappy family had died of tuberculosis
adlet yam is considered one of the
oldest known human settlements and one
of the earliest to present evidence of
cattle farming this detail seemed to
confirm an early theory that human tb
may have originated from bovine tb
humans can get infected from cows that
are infected with their disease and that
is why we pasteurize milk but m
tuberculosis and m bovis are two
separate bacterial strains which
originated independently albeit from a
common ancestor there is an indirect
link however between the spread of human
tb and the practice of herding animals
when humans evolved from
hunter-gatherers to farmers they started
living in larger communities with
increased population density and larger
families living under the same roof
there were simply more chances for
infection as the earliest civilizations
dawned on our planet they unwittingly
helped the cruel bacillus to grow and
the disease left its indelible mark
cases of a disease similar to tb were
documented in egyptian texts more than 5
000 years ago and some mummies even
presented skeletal deformities typical
of potts disease if there were any
doubts about the presence of tb in
ancient egypt these were wiped out by
pathologist professor andreas nerlich in
1997 he identified traces of them
tuberculosis dna in tissues extracted
from a mummy according to medical
historian dr dm daniel indirect
references to the prevalence of the
disease in egypt can even be found in
the bible in leviticus 26 16 after moses
has led the israelites away from slavery
in egypt god warns his people what could
happen should they violate his covenant
i will do this to you i will bring on
you sudden terror wasting diseases and
fever that will destroy your sight and
sap your strength a similar punishment
for disobedience appears in deuteronomy
28 22 with the same reference to a
wasting disease according to rabbinical
tradition the book of leviticus was
written around some 3400 years ago this
was around the same time that tb was
described in india in a sanskrit him and
sometime later in a chinese medical text
the spread of the disease was not
limited to africa and eurasia of course
tb was once believed to have reached the
americas stowed away inside the lungs of
conquistadors and other european
colonizers but a 1994 research paper by
dr w.l salo at the university of
minnesota found traces of em
tuberculosis and a peruvian mummy of the
10th century a.d this proved that the
disease had been wasting away bodies in
america well ahead of columbus's landing
now in a video that features so much
death and disease we really don't need
to remind you about the importance of
life insurance nobody likes to think
about their own mortal coil but the
reality is that it's an important layer
of protection for many families
especially single-income households
fortunately this policy genius and their
award-winning policy options ranked
number one by forbes whether you've been
putting off your purchase or you just
never really thought about it policy
genius is the team that you want to
check in with this is a third-party
marketplace that works for you not for
the insurance company so you can trust
that their license experts are going to
give you solid and unbiased advice life
insurance premiums might seem like a
financial drain but you could save 1 300
or more per year by using policy genius
to compare life insurance policies if
you're interested head to
policygenius.com to get started in just
a few minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and the scheduling for free
you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius and getting covered now
locks in your rate over the course of a
10 or 20 year policy those savings
really do add up and best of all
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as one week so head to
policygenius.com to get started you will
be glad you did because when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right now
let's get back to our video
[Music]
by the 5th century bc tuberculosis was
well known in greece the father of
medicine hippocrates called it tysus and
ranked it as the most considerable
disease he also noted that it mainly
felled young adults aged 18 to 35. what
it failed to recognize was that this was
an infectious disease and it would be
centuries before medical science reached
that conclusion
the ailment later known as consumption
was believed to be a consequence of poor
diet poor living standards or simply
inherited from parents and ancestors
greek physician galen working for roman
emperor marcus aurelius in 174 a.d
recommended a course of treatment for
fresh air milk and sea voyages after the
fall of the western roman empire there's
little written record of tb in europe
the only exception is the condition
known as scrofulo caused when m
tuberculosis infects the lymph nodes in
the neck king clover's the first of the
franks initiated a curious practice in
496 a.d the royal touch according to
tradition frankish and later french and
british monarchs had the power to heal
skarafula with their hands you sit on a
throne of lies the tradition continued
until the reign of queen anne of great
britain and ireland in the early 18th
century despite the privilege of
requiring a monarch for its treatment
scraffola did not appear to be a major
concern during the middle ages probably
because it was overshadowed by the big
plague pandemics of the 6th and 14th
centuries or the recurrent famines it
was only in the mid-17th century
authorities had to take notice of the
huge toll exacted by consumption by then
also known as white plague the london
bills of mortality of the time recorded
that 20 percent of all deaths in the
city were due to consumption medical
schools across europe took a keen
interest in finding the causes of the
disease in 1650 the university of paris
expressed doubts that isis may have a
contagious nature but the commonly
accepted view was that tb was due to a
hereditary defect as it appears
particularly severe in certain families
despite advances in medical sciences and
living standards the tb epidemic
continued to grow out of proportion
during the 18th century the industrial
revolution with consequent growth of
cities and increased population density
may have played a part as it had
happened millennia earlier the bacillus
curse could not forgive our evolutionary
leaps mortality due to tb peaked around
the 1780s its death rate in england
being 1.25 percent that's between 90 and
100 deaths per thousand more poignantly
it was estimated that one out of every
four deaths in england was attributable
to the disease
this was a catastrophe worse than war
famine crime industrial accidents
natural disasters or any other disease
known to mankind tuberculosis was
widespread ubiquitous sudden persistent
it was as common as life and death
themselves and yet the 19th century
reacted by romanticizing it consumption
sufferers were described as live pale
melancholic souls bathed in an almost
supernatural aura coughing blood and
wasting a weight and nothing was almost
considered fashionable to the upper
levels of society the poe lord byron
once remarked to a friend that he would
have liked to die of consumption because
the ladies would all say look at that
poor byron how interesting he looks in
dying the fashionable aspect was fed by
the false belief that consumption
affected fine delicate precocious people
who dabbled in dissolute living in other
words an interesting way of dying for
people who led interesting lives for
example consumption seemed to be
particularly prominent among artists to
name a few in the 19th century the
illness claimed the geniuses of poet
john keats frederick chopin and all the
bronte sisters in the early 20th century
playwright anton chekhov painter amadeo
modigliani and france kafka all join
them in palliative demise another school
of thought attributed a rather more
sinister origin to the wasting disease
vampirism in her book catching breath
researcher catherine lockheed tells the
story of a new england family the rays
between 1845 and 1851 mr ray and two of
his sons died of consumption in 1854
another son henry began to feel ill
henry's extended family and friends
started to worry how could they save him
not grasping the concept of infection
they concluded that the undead rays were
feeding on henry at night the locals
exhumed the father and the two siblings
discovering fresh blood inside the heart
of one of them they burned the organ
rearranged the bones of the alleged
vampire and buried him again of course
henry lived happily ever after for about
two months then his condition worsened
and he died surprise surprise it wasn't
vampires something similar happened
again in new england to a young man
called edwin brown in this case edwin's
friends burns the heart of his sister
mercy collected the ashes and made a
remedial potion for him to drink no
surprise there poor edwin followed mercy
and other relatives to an early grave
what is surprising about the brown case
is that it took place in 1892. ten years
earlier german physician robert cox had
identified the cause of the ancient
curse mycobacterium tuberculosis
but let's proceed in order between 1803
and 1819 french doctor renee leyneck
made a significant contribution in the
fight against tv back then consumption
scruffola and other conditions were
still believed to be separate ailments
leneck argued that they all shared a
common cause the presence of small
lesions in the lungs lymph nodes spine
or other organs twenty years later
german doctor johan lukashonline named
these legions tubercules and the disease
tuberculosis now would have become
easier for physicians to identify and
diagnose the condition thanks also to
another one of lennox contributions the
stethoscope but still they could offer
little in terms of treatments not much
had changed since the times of galen
patients were prescribed healthy diets
and outdoor activities such as horseback
riding even better if the treatment was
administered in one of the dedicated
sanatoria active since 1859. six years
later another french doctor jour antoine
villemon made a major breakthrough in
animal experiments he proved that the
sputum of a consumptive child could
infect a rabbit tuberculosis had finally
been recognized as an infectious disease
at this stage dr entered the fray
determined to isolate the microbe
responsible for tb the physician used
tubercules extracted from the lungs of
infected animals crushed them and spread
them on glass after some trial and error
he found the appropriate staining agents
methylene blue with the addition of
potassium hydroxide after a 24-hour
exposure described how quote
verifying rod-like forms became apparent
in the tubercular mass for the first
time he had identified the tubercle
bacillus or mycobacterium tuberculosis
as we know it today published his
findings in 1882 a scientific discovery
which made headlines across the world
but there was still much road to cover
before a cure could be found
himself had extracted from tuberculosis
tissue a substance called tuberculin
which he believed could be a cure it
proved to be ineffective at treating tb
but it was very reliable at diagnosing
it for several decades surgery appeared
as the only curative option in 1896
italian surgeon carlo forliani routinely
introduced a procedure called artificial
pneumothorax or surgically induced
collapsed lung the method had been first
tried by dr ramdage in london in 1834
and he had taken inspiration from
another italian doctor who in the late
17th century had found that a
consumptive patient had improved after a
sword wound had caused his lung to
collapse clinical trials in the 1920s
and 30s showed that this procedure was
efficacious in up to 70 of tuberculosis
patients of course it was incredibly
invasive and had plenty of side effects
the alternative was even worse though
thoracoplasty this surgical technique
was designed to collapse tuberculosis
cavities by the resection of ribs from
the chest wall so how about prevention a
vaccine was introduced in 1921 by french
bacteriologists albert calmet and camil
guerin who developed an attenuated
strain of m bovis callius which could be
inoculated in children the vaccine known
as the bcg is still used in several
countries science marched on unstoppable
in 1944 ukrainian microbiologist salman
avaxman working at rutgers university
new jersey discovered an efficacious
curative agent antimicrobial
streptomyosin in 1948 the who and unicef
launched a massive anti-tb campaign
nearly 30 million people were treated
with tuberculin and those who resulted
negative received a shot of bcg another
leap forward took place in 1952 with the
successful testing of isoniazid the
first oral
microbactericidal drug the discovery was
followed by the introduction of further
antibiotic therapies in the late 1950s
and early 1960s pyrazimide thamyatol and
ryphambusin are still the backbone of
current anti-tb therapy the curse of
humankind was slowly being defeated at
least in industrialized countries drugs
played an important role of course
alongside better sanitation educational
campaigns and the establishment of
public health practices to give you an
example the rate of deaths from tb in
england and the u.s was about 190 per
hundred thousand people in 1900 by 1960
it had dropped to six or seven in the
west tuberculosis had become an almost
forgotten relic of the past remembered
as little more than a plot device to
kill off the heroine of an italian
romantic opera but in other parts of the
world the enemy remained vigilant
stubborn
lethal
figures from the cdc and the who
indicate that in 2018 to 2019 1.7
billion people were infected with m
tuberculosis every year about 10 million
new people become ill with the disease
of them about 1.5 million will die
according to the who this makes tb the
world's top infectious killer 84 of all
fatalities are aged 15 or above and more
than half of men about 13 roughly 200
000 are hiv-positive patients who are at
greater risk of contracting and dying
from tb the distribution of the disease
is far from homogenous as almost 90 of
cases are concentrated in 30 countries
mainly developing nations in which the
spread of tb is facilitated by poverty
poor sanitation and lack of healthcare
infrastructure about half of all
tuberculosis patients are found in just
eight countries bangladesh china india
indonesia nigeria pakistan philippines
and south africa and yet i should stress
that tb is now curable with a standard
six-month course of poor antibiotics but
it is a complex treatment requiring
support and supervision where these are
not consistent a patient may not fully
comply with the therapy and the disease
can become drug resistant the who
identifies drug-resistant tb as a public
health threat a 2019 report estimated
that close to half a million patients
have developed resistance to standard
antibiotics even if patients are being
correctly treated and supported they are
at risk of dying from an underlying
comorbidity in 2014 dr chow han lin
published a study reviewing the medical
history of 2016 db positive taiwanese
patients 249 of them died over the
2003-2
period but only 17 percent succumbed to
tb the rest died of other causes such as
tumors cardiovascular disease or other
bacterial infections add another
complication at the time of producing
this video health services worldwide
fighting against the covet-19 pandemic
the disruption placed on health services
may reduce the diagnosis and treatment
of tb cases by 25 to 50 percent which
could increase the global death toll of
tuberculosis by 400 000 casualties in
2020 alone moreover the economic impact
of the pandemic may worsen gdp per
capita and under nutrition to key risk
factors which contribute to increased
incidence of the disease wh modeling has
suggested that in 2020 to 2025 period
the number of tb cases could increase by
more than 1 million per year progress
has been made and is being made to rid
humanity of its most stubborn antagonist
the leaders of all u.n member states
have committed to ending this global
epidemic by 2030 backed up by concrete
milestones and targets at the end of
2019 global indicators for the reduction
in disease burden in several high
prevalence countries were moving in the
right direction but at global levels
progress is not on track and the covid19
emergency is threatening to hinder or
even reverse what improvements have been
achieved but is there an end in sight
catherine lockheed who i already quoted
argues that the evolutionary paths of
humanity and m tuberculosis are
intertwined closely nip together
pandemics have come and gone diseases
have been eradicated but tb has always
been the constant drone in the
background for all its fashionable aura
in the 19th century tb has been and is a
disease which thrives on poverty
overcrowding and inequality which are
also constant backdrops to the story of
humans on earth medical science and
zebra is progressing as of august 2021
the
globaldiseasedatabaseclinicaltrials.gov
a total of 845 clinical studies looking
for new tuberculosis treatments 138 of
them are in the late phase 3 stage which
looks promising for the future but
medical science may not be enough of a
solution in lockheed's words until we
see universal improvement in living
conditions access to healthcare the
effects of poverty and all the other
markers of inequality then tb
is going nowhere
so i hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]